the people of Alabama vote today and one
of the most closely watched special
elections in US history both Senate
candidates Republican Roy Moore and
Democrat Doug Jones held rallies last
night to try and boost support and try
and convince some undecided voters
Alabama has not elected a Democratic
senator in 25 years as latest polling
Scholz
shows whether this race is very much in
the air and will go right down to the
wire a Fox News survey suggests that
Jones has a 10-point lead but an emerson
poll has more ad by nine points turnout
will likely determine the winner of this
race Manuel Bojorquez is in Dothan
Alabama where Moore held his last
campaign rally Manuel good morning good
morning both Moore and Jones stumped
last night with a number of politicians
and entertainers even athletes it was a
last-minute push to energize voters in a
contest for a Senate seat that is very
much in play and we're not going to
stand by and let other people from out
of state and money from California
control this election on the eve of
Tuesday's election Roy Moore painted
himself as the victim of outside special
interests and rejected multiple
allegations of sexual misconduct if you
don't believe in my character don't vote
for me
Moore's wife Kayla defended her husband
against allegations of sexism racism and
anti-semitism which she blamed the media
for spreading so I just want to set the
record straight while they're here
one of our attorneys is it you former
White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon said the race is a referendum on
President Trump this is a national
election but he also took a shot at
Ivanka Trump who recently criticized
more saying there's a special place in
hell for people who prey on children
there's a special place in hell for
Republicans who should know better
meanwhile in Birmingham Moore's
Democratic rival Doug Jones urged his
supporters to get to the polls it's just
time that we say no more and former NBA
star and Alabama native Charles Barkley
said mores politics are holding the
state back listen I love Alabama but at
some point we got to draw a line in the
sand so we just we're not a bunch of
down idiots in a rather unusual moment
at Roy Moore's rally last night his
friend bill sailing recalled a story
from the time they both served in
Vietnam
sailing told the crowd that during their
tour he and more were unknowingly taken
to a brothel with very young girls
he claimed when Moore realized it was a
brothel he immediately had them both
leave the polls here close tonight at
7:00 man well thank you I mean you can't
make it up sometimes the comments that
were made in a very unusual story to
share at this time under these
circumstances I would agree all this at
the point you're making John I asked you
because there we have those two
conflicting polls what do you make of
that and the other thing that's
interesting me is there's been no early
voting so today really matters it really
matters I think would you say about the
polls is that if we had tea in one of
these cups and we looked at the leaves
we might be able to get better get a
better sense of what's happening than
looking at the polls polls in a special
election or hard because you don't know
what kind of electorate is going to turn
out Alabama is not a state that has a
lot of polling like saying New Hampshire
or Iowa in in presidential contests and
then you have the radioactivity of this
race and the fact that if you're polling
on the phone to a Republican they may
not want to admit they're there a Roy
Moore voter and and so
you really don't know and thank goodness
it's election day so we can actually get
a result and and stop having to guess so
and and of course we must say it all
comes down to turnout which is like
saying water is wet and we will have the
results here tomorrow morning this